sie ist das Flaggschiff der freien Welt
das ist schon unbeschreiblich wenn man
hier neben einem startenden Jet steht
der Boden vibriert das ist unfassbar
laut
sie ist die ultimative Waffe
sie ist das größte und teuerste
Kriegsschiff das jemals gebaut wurde die
USS Gerald are Ford
und es ist absolut beeindruckend mit
welcher Präzision der Pilot hier gleich
eines der drei fangen seine erwischen
würden
[Musik]
Sizilien unweit der Stadt Catania zu
Füßen des ätnahs Reporter Sebastian
Prengel ist auf dem Weg zum größten
Flugzeugträger der Welt wir sind jetzt
hier an der Airbase auf Sizilien und von
hier aus starten wir gleich mit einer
Grammeln Greyhound Propellermaschine auf
zum teuersten Schiff der Weltgeschichte
aller Zeiten aber wir müssen natürlich
erstmal hinkommen und der Flug dahin der
wird so ungefähr zwei Stunden dauern
[Musik]
Sicherheitseinweisung die Landung auf
einem Flugzeugträger ist nicht
ungefährlich
[Musik]
keiner dürfen
weil der Träger immer in Bewegung ist
weiß niemand wie lange genau der Flug
dauern wird
es ist heiß eng und dunkel wer am
Fenster sitzt hat Glück es gibt nur
eines pro Seite
hier im Flugzeug ist es wirklich extrem
laut also mit dem Komfort eines normalen
Linienflugs hat das hier rein gar nichts
zu tun und wir sind auf festgezogen
können uns kaum bewegen das ist aber
deshalb wichtig weil die Landung extrem
hart wird das heißt also von 220 auf 0
geht es ungefähr zwei Sekunden
[Musik]
nur die Piloten können den Flug genießen
doch dann beginnt der Landeanflug
und schließlich kommt das Zeichen
[Musik]
dann ist es schließlich geschafft wir
stehen auf dem größten Kriegsschiff der
Welt
4.539 Frauen und Männer beherbergt die
schwimmen der Stadt es braucht zwei
Atomreaktoren um sie mit Energie zu
versorgen
[Musik]
die USS Ford ist eine Waffe der
Superlative allein die Maße sind
gigantisch das Schiff ist 337 Meter lang
fast 80 Meter hoch
[Musik]
das war eine harte Landung und was man
jetzt hier direkt sieht das ist ein
Labyrinth dieses Schiffe es geht hier
eine Leiter runter noch eine Leiter noch
eine Leiter und wenn man sich hier nicht
auskennt dann kann man sich sehr schnell
verlaufen das ist einfach riesengroß
für Ihre aktuelle Mission hat die fort
über 75 Flugzeuge an Bord vor allem
Kampfjets vom Typ F18 super Hornet dem
unverwüstlichen Arbeitstier der US Navy
18 Kampfjets gewartet repariert aber
auch mit riesigen Zusatztanks und
Waffensystemen bestückt und wir hören
über uns auch immer wieder das Donnern
der staatenden Maschinen und wir schauen
uns hier einmal um und wir sehen es ja
hier eine F18 neben der anderen das sind
schon sehr imposante Bilder zur Zeit ist
die USS Ford Flaggschiff des
nato-manövers neptunstrike führt eine
alliierte NATO Flotte in der Adria an
der Kommandeur ist unser Gastgeber
ry professional energy question's
[Musik]
es geht hinaus auf das Flugzeug live und
aus nächster Nähe werden wir den Start
einer Staffel Kampfjets erleben
hinter uns macht sich gerade ein F18
Kampfjet für seinen Einsatz bereit wir
schauen uns das einmal genauer an das
Katapult wird fertig gemacht und dann
beschleunigt erklärt innerhalb von
wenigen Metern auf die Start
geständigkeit und das Dröhnen der
Turbinen das nennen die Amerikaner sound
of freedom
sound of freedom der Klang der Freiheit
und 30 % mehr Staats- und Landungen kann
die USS Ford mit weniger Personal
bewältigen als die Schiffe ihrer
Vorgänger klasse
steht der Boden vibriert das ist
unfassbar laut und natürlich ist das
eine Machtdemonstration in Richtung
sagen wir Putin auch wenn die NATO hier
ganz diplomatisch von Abschreckung und
Verteidigung
fast zehn Jahre dauert der Bau des mega
Schiffes weitere zehn Jahre dauert es
bis das Schiff einsatzbereit ist
hochgeschwindigkeitstestfahrten gehören
dazu genauso wie schocktests
mit riesigen unterwasserexplosionen wird
dabei getestet wie das Schiff auf
extreme Belastungen reagiert
[Musik]
erst danach beginnen die Flugtests vor
allem die neuartige Katapult und
landeanlage wird extremen Tests
unterzogen
[Musik]
am Ende belaufen sich allein die
Baukosten auf 13 Milliarden Dollar
insgesamt 36 Milliarden Dollar sollen am
Ende für Forschung und Entwicklung
aufgewendet worden sein
[Musik]
wir sind mit Christoph Hille verabredet
der ist in Hannover geboren jetzt
Amerikaner und kümmert sich um
Schleudersitze und Klimaanlagen von
Kampfjets
was
für ein Testgerät wo wir praktisch
simulieren können dass wir in 15.000 Fuß
fliegen und die verschiedene Tests
machen können ob in unser System
arbeiten
Christophs Arbeitstag beginnt um 4:30
Uhr und dauert 12 Stunden für ihn der
Traumjob
ist ja ein riesiges
Schild mal dass man die Wellen ein
bisschen stärker sind oder ist immer
alles glatt nee dieser ab und zu merken
das jetzt schon oder mehrere schon jetzt
zurzeit hier gerade in der Adria nicht
wirklich weil die Wellen wirklich sehr
flach sind
wirklich richtig sehen kann ist ab 5
Meter Wellenbewegung aufwärts was eben
im Nordatlantik auch mal passieren kann
bei so einem Seegang dann auch noch
Flugzeuge starten und landen
kommt drauf an je nach Wetterlage wie
gesagt sollte ist aber auch ist aber
auch möglich aber meistens aus
Vorsichtsmaßnahmen wird er jeden davon
abgesehen
leben arbeiten Freizeit all das
geschieht auf der USS fort zwischen
Kampfjets
[Musik]
also ziemlich ungewöhnlich eine Hund auf
dem Flugzeugträger zu treffen kannst du
uns mal erklären was damit auf sich hat
ja das hier ist age sie ist unser
Therapiehund und sie begleitet uns jetzt
das erste Mal dass das erste Mal dass
sie hier auf dem Schiff mit dabei ist
und jetzt eben ja rund um die betreut
und geben sie mal ein bisschen
Abwechslung und sie kommt im um zu
Besuch und zaubert jedem ein Lächeln auf
dem ausgesucht jetzt muss ich mal ganz
doof fragen es gibt hier keine Wiese auf
dem Flugzeugträger wo macht der Hund
sein Geschäft ähm die ist irgendwo
untergebracht und sie haben wohl den
Bereich für sie so gestaltet dass es
eben ja wie nach Rasen aussieht also
praktisch hundegerecht hundegericht
gehalten wird sie hat eben den eigenen
Bereich und dann ja tut sie eben das
Schiff ab und zu
super
[Musik]
hier auf der Brücke wird das Schiff
gesteuert und wir sehen hier im
Hintergrund die drei Männer die haben
das Ruder in der Hand und die führen
hier die Befehle des Captains aus und
bestimmen natürlich dann halt auch
welchen Kurs das Schiff nimmt und wir
hören im Hintergrund immer wieder dieses
donnernde Dröhnen der F18 Kampfjets die
Staaten hier und landen und das zeigt
natürlich dass man auf diesem Schiff
immer arbeitet hier hat man nie seine
Ruhe die Soldaten die sind hier
jederzeit einsatzbereit
[Musik]
[Applaus]
wieder zurück und wir schauen einmal
hinter mich da ist eine Maschine im
Anflug und die mal Geschwindigkeit die
liegt ungefähr bei etwas über 200 km/h
und es ist absolut beeindruckend mit
welcher Präzision der Pilot hier gleich
eines der drei fangen seine erwischen
wird
[Musik]
seit Mai 2023 befindet sich die USS
Jared awford auf ihrer ersten Mission